i've always been curious how did you
convince book walker
a japanese company to start to start
working with like western youtubers
because
i remember that like yeah i want to know
how that works the first the first time
yeah joey was the first one but i think
book walker was the first japanese
company
ever contacted me i think like or still
now one of the only ones
that have like ever gone out and
contacted contacted us yeah without book
or care yeah yeah yeah and
that was your idea right yeah so so how
did you convince them to do that
i mean before uh i guess using youtubers
i'm using youtube oh we milked them dry
that's a bad way i'm sorry before
collaborating there we go
get those buzzwords yeah because i was
doing marketing
for them and i guess i still was i'm not
in book walker o'clock right now
but i've tried so many things i've done
like
sns ads or collaborations with
cosplayers or
fan art artists right okay and i
worked with anime clubs and i think oh
yeah i worked with anime clubs wow
because they had movement
movie nights or they want to have i
don't know so you sponsor the movie
nights
yeah yeah you paid them we gave them
like free books to say oh okay maybe you
guys should read it because the idea was
they're going to be the ambassador of
their community
right and if you give them like free
manga they'll check it out and then
they'll give it to their friends
yeah yeah yeah if only there was some
way to just reach a ton of people
really easily like the internet or
something yeah i actually didn't yeah so
i was like
around like like what's bigger than an
anime club what's bigger than
we gonna think bigger yeah
four four or four years ago five years
ago yeah i think it was like five
four five years ago now uh so i didn't
even know that anime youtube was a thing
i knew
like anime music videos um very illegal
illegal stuff yeah
in their eyes i've made anime music
videos
fired from books no
uh but yeah so i just knew about that
type of like
anime youtube but then i was a big
follower of
a lot of like japanese vloggers not
japanese folks japan vloggers like jb
vloggers and then joey appeared in one
of
the videos of the person that i was
watching and i was like this person's
called anime
so you didn't even know he was an anime
youtuber no if he wasn't called the
anime man
you would you wouldn't have like looked
into it right now
i think you weren't even talking about
anime if i wasn't a j vlogger
i think it was like sharla's video
sharla in japan
oh yeah yeah i mean if i'm collabing
with j vloggers i'm not going to talk
about like i can talk about
yeah i i don't think i was talking about
anime at that point
i don't remember i think you were like
mixing drinks in a royal host
oh yeah something something maybe i
don't know yeah i go
i not googled you i just clicked your
videos and then
i just started watching i was like what
there's people that review
anime why would anyone want to watch
that
i hate reading i hate reading people's
comments
like for example videos on the bottom
comments yeah yeah yeah yeah
i hate reading them yeah yeah yeah
because you know they
might not like the same character
whatever yeah i don't want people to say
they don't like what i like yeah
maybe some garbage opinion like dubs are
better than subs or something
and i was like i don't agree but let's
see if he like
likes manga and then i emailed
and i was like oh not gonna lie the
first time i got your email
and it said like from like you know it
was like color yeah
i was just like whoa fishy i think this
might be
fish i think this might be a fishing
email
i actually thought the same because i
remember the first time you emailed me
immediate delete because i'm just like
there's no way there's no way this is
legit
there's no way this is legit i mean i
did email you and then i asked joey's
like
you know i think this other anime tuber
is not at
all because i was like there's no way
catechol was emailing me like
that
at that time yeah yeah because i've
never heard a book walker i've ever seen
you count a cow but i'm
just like what is what is this shady
company
what is this shady company that's using
caterpillar's name i'm like yeah there's
no way this is
legitimately like i i got the email
because i was living in australia still
at the time i'm pretty sure to move here
it was like
six months yeah yeah yeah yeah i was
already in japan that's right and i
remember like i sent that email like
i forwarded to my mom and dad just to be
like english
does this look legit like i don't i'm
really scared to rewind
english yeah why is it
if it ends up being a fish whatever yeah
that was the best email i ever sent
because i asked you to come to the
office too
that's right that's right yeah and then
when you gave me the address and i
looked it up on google maps i'm like
okay this is legit
yeah because it's actually in one of the
colleges yeah yeah yeah exactly
i think i heard was it true that like
katakawa just didn't like they wanted to
meet
the youtuber before they didn't it's not
all it's just japanese businesses in
general like to know if they're a real
person or just you know
like just the idea of judge if they're
good people so like that
if joey wasn't in japan right yeah would
there possibly have been
no collaboration because like if joey
our first conversation was actually on
skype
right right would have been good enough
to secure a deal do you reckon
probably not probably not unless there's
like a foreigner in the group like
at that time i was like the only
foreigner working
yeah because i remember like when i went
to the book walker office as well that
was like
probably the first time i ever went to
like a like a physical
meeting in japan and since then god i've
every time a japanese company is like
we'd like to meet up with you to discuss
this thing i'm like
do you know what email is it's i don't
want to leave i think without like
i mean you guys starting it i feel like
they wouldn't have even considered
youtubers right i almost
almost feel like the japanese companies
it took me like four months to get a
proof no not four months maybe two
months
to get approved which is actually
incredibly fast compared to some of the
other projects
my number changing my email change i had
to like do
i guess bs a lot of bs a lot of like
data oh my god i'm gonna get caught
i'll be like did you cook the books
i crunched the numbers i made graphs i
was like the inflow from youtube
is like the best for i don't know
reaching the hearts
of teenagers
yeah so i i still probably have that
slide and i was like
quantify how well youtubers can reach
their viewers